[Applause]
the build-up has been immense stages and
seating studios and union flags all
dressing one of the world's most famous
backdrops for a moment britain has never
seen before
service and duty will be the central
themes of this platinum jubilee the
military kicking off proceedings with
trooping the color they have been
rehearsing for months for the
traditional birthday parade for the
queen which this year will march past a
new addition the tree of trees
part of a project encouraging people to
plant saplings to mark the jubilee and
due to be lit up at the end of the day
along with thousands of other beacons
across the country and commonwealth the
queen's already done this
incredible legacy of planting trees
herself i mean she must personally be
one of the biggest tree planters over
her
90 years of life
you just have to look at everything that
they have created and this enormous
build that's gone on around buckingham
palace to see just how much the
organizers are going out of their way to
make sure it is a weekend that none of
us will ever forget for the queen though
this isn't just going to be about her
achievements because of everything we've
been through with kovid she wants to
make sure it's also a celebration of all
of those who've served their communities
like the chairworld collective near
oxford set up during the pandemic and
again bringing the community together
big celebration like this you can spend
a whole lot of money but you're not
doing that here are you we're gonna have
a incredible beautiful setup here having
not spent any money
all of the food comes from surplus from
the food industry and then the bunting
we've been making out of like donated
curtains old sheets that people have
given us
sunday will again be a celebration of
britain at its best from rehearsal rooms
ladies and gentlemen that's fabulous the
hangers preparations underway for the
jubilee pageant that will take place
around the palace all the rock stars
were sort of lined up and the minute she
came down they all you know they all
sort of stood into line and all babe
opera singer catherine jenkins will be
there she has performed for the queen
many times before and even had lunch
with her and prince philip everybody's
always very very excited to meet her so
um no i i think that you know she
obviously
is the star of this whole um weekend and
um and i think everybody will be turning
out to just to wish her well and
congratulate her
inevitably the world will also be
watching her family some already in
celebratory mood with the sussexes
flying in from america and questions
about whether we'll see prince andrew
seen today in windsor
but whatever has happened in the past
they are pulling out all the stops to
keep our focus on one woman and a
remarkable 70 years as queen
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace